so when we're looking at assessing the
students working we're looking an awful
lot at their work on their project more
so than the actual project itself and
we're also thinking about what did they
learn and what can they demonstrate that
they've learned from the project so a
fair chunk of their assessment is making
sure they're in class and participating
and that's actually a separate from
projects and then within the project
we're looking at how well they managed
and ran their project and work together
on a group to get their projects done
and that has less that again has less to
do with how the project turned out and
more with how they worked on it we've
got about an equal chunk on does the
project meet the specified requirements
for the from the assignment as we say
we're not actually looking for good
games here we don't expect you guys to
come up with good games given all the
constraints we've piled on you in the
time you have what we want to know is
can you make a reasonably complete game
that fits all the requirements we've put
on we've given you and runs well and
then the final chunk is their own
personal reflection we ask after every
project we ask each of them to write an
essay basically it's a short essay but
it's talking about what they did on
their project what worked well what
didn't work well what changes they would
make to the process and to the project
on their next project because we really
want them to be learning from these
experiences and so what we're really
looking for is proof that they have
learned something and it's going to
affect the way they work going forward